hello welcome to my talk we're gonna go
over system sleep I know you're all
really excited and I'm excited because
you all decided to come in here and
spend an hour listening to me as I try
to convince you not to do anything like
at all just don't even touch your app
okay so I guess the first question is
why should you listen to me
here's a copy of my bio from the website
you can read it again if you want to but
not listed on this is I I work at Google
obviously I meant developer advocate for
Android and recently I co-founded this
initiative called Android development
patterns we have a bunch of videos
online we put out pro tips every week
and the intent here is to teach people
how to do best practices how to build
better apps by knowing how to make a
decision as opposed to how to implement
an API because we have a lot of coverage
on the Java Docs and in our
documentation and on our the videos on
how things work and we want to teach win
and why things work and then how to make
that decision am I talking too fast
sorry okay and so that's what ADP is
about the other thing that I did this
year that's really cool is I created the
advanced Android app development course
with Udacity and so we have a super cool
nano degree which is awesome teaches you
everything you need to know or just the
pieces that you might have missed and my
course is the second part of that and
once you've learned the basics of
operating system you want to learn the
fancier things like maybe how to
integrate with Google Cloud messenger
and so that's the kind of stuff that we
cover and we're really trying to help
you build not just a simple sample app
but like just walk you through how
something works in its entirety and when
you have to go back and iterate on the
same app that you've already finished
we're trying to get more into that
developer experience when we're teaching
and so that it feels more true to what
your your life isn't your experience is
going to be and then if it helps I
actually started learning Android last
February 2014 and so I just want to say
that as like a point of hopefully like
comfort you don't have to have been
doing this since the beginning and you
don't have to been doing this for a very
long time to really pick it up and like
run with it because it does change every
year and you can really get caught up
quickly okay so maybe listen to me but
if you don't that's okay so today the
reason we are all in this room is
because battery
actually matters almost more than
anything else that we have and there has
been tons of press on this you see
studies all the time comparing this
device to that device which one runs
better or this carrier to that carrier
this one's clearly better for battery
doesn't burn your radio or you know buy
this new thing because this tablet will
last all month and this other one will
only last a couple of days and everybody
really cares about getting power but
nobody wants to give up using and so
it's kind of a trade-off and this is
this big problem for users that
everyone's trying to solve so what we're
going to talk about is how to solve this
by not making it worse with background
tasks and so clearly you know how this
works you've got your activity kicks off
at background tasks your activity
continues this is good for users because
you're not hanging up on the frame rate
but this is bad for is the it's the
device because we get into this
situation where every app kicks off its
own background sync or a job and none of
them are talking to anybody else and
nobody knows what's going on everybody
just knows like I want to get this done
at some point and it doesn't really
matter when so long as it's done in time
when I need it and this is what's worse
because all of these things if you can't
coalesce them you can't optimize for
them so we want to at the end of our
talk move to this we want to be able to
say three different apps need to run a
sync by this time or under these
conditions run them all together and
then later on another app needs to run a
sync like let's run that one when you
can't like we want to be able to do this
in bulk every time we can and not every
30 minutes for somebody new and this is
what's going to save the device battery
the most because we can just not wake up
the CPU if it's not being used and we
can not drain the power when nobody's
even in the room which brings us to doze
mode doze mode was introduced in Android
marshmallow and the reason that it was
introduced was so that we could as a
framework take control other apps don't
have insight into what everyone is doing
and you can only go so far to make your
app okay but if the framework doesn't
help
we can't ever get to that ideal state so
unfortunately it doesn't really matter
what API you're targeting if your users
on a marshmallow device this is going to
affect you it goes back with your all
SDKs for any device that actually
supports marshmallow and that's why you
need to start thinking about it today
because you you won't know if your users
are really affected or not
so with the dose we released this we got
a lot of kind of press a lot of you know
really good feedback from the developer
community so you would think we'd have a
really good list of goals for why we did
it
but we don't we only have one we just
want to preserve the battery life
because by doing that we're creating a
better user experience and that's what
everyone like when you're creating an
operating system you need to emphasize
so this is our one goal Firdos do
whatever we need to to preserve battery
when we're in an idle state when the
users not using it we need to do
everything we can so that when they pick
their phone back up or exactly at the
17% that they had left but I have my own
goal for this talk and here's that goal
I want you to learn to accept that your
user has a life you're all you're
spending so long building this great app
that you're really invested in and you
want your users to use and that's great
like you should keep doing that but you
should understand what success means
when we're talking about an app at
Google we we actually count success like
Larry Page will be super proud of you if
you can pass his toothbrush test and
that means if your user is using your
product two times a day for a couple of
minutes a day that is successful so
we're going for like what five minutes
here which means there's 23 hours and 55
minutes and every day when your user is
not interacting with your app but you're
super duper successful and when you
think about it like that it changes the
way that you actually design your app
because you're not going for them using
your app all day long you're not going
for constant glue to the thing tripping
over getting run over by a car you're
going for something that's useful that
they'll come back to and tell their
friends about which means you don't need
to be updating every 20 minutes you just
need to be ready when they're using you
which goes into what is dode
so doses when your device is fully idle
and what does that actually mean so what
we've got here is network access is
blocked if the device is not being used
if we're in idle mode we don't allow
network access by anyone we just turn
off the radio and that's gonna save us
so much battery we also ignore wakelocks
sorry we're in Joe's mode we don't
really care that you wanted to do
something or go on for any further any
alarms that you set with your alarm
manager those are gonna be deferred
they're not gonna run while we're in
doze but because we'll have missed the
time window to all trigger as soon as we
exit out of doze mode
and finally your sinks and jobs they
just won't run they won't get deleted
they won't get dropped but they will not
run through doze mode which means when
we exit doze mode and all those
conditions are met again we'll run them
as soon as we exit unless of course your
time to life has expired because it's no
longer relevant but we're not just
deleting them because we're in idle mode
and I know that this sounds kind of
frustrating and kind of scary because as
a developer you you need to know that
you're the state that your app is gonna
be in and it seems like this framework
is standing up here telling you like we
don't really care we're deleting all of
your hard work and that's really not
true which goes back to my first point
of in 43 more minutes I want you to walk
out of here thinking I'm not going to
change my app because I'm not being hurt
or damaged I'm just being maybe delayed
so let's talk about how we get into doze
mode doze mode is triggered when the
device is not charging and the screen is
off and the device has not moved in a
long while so what that looks like with
your phone I put it down I kind of walk
away I'm doing something more important
like talking to you guys but when I come
back over there I better still be at 58%
I'm going to be really frustrated if I
get back here at the end of this hour
and I'm down to 13 because I was playing
a game with my friends and it kept
updating while I wasn't using it like
that's just not a good developer
experience we really need users to trust
that their devices in the state that
they left it so the trade-off though is
that as soon as I put it down I'm not
already dozing like it doesn't happen as
soon as these three conditions are met
we're actually going to step into it
this is a timeline of what does looks
like we start with like everything that
was required to get into doze and then
you'll see that doze actually will give
itself some maintenance window so we'll
come back to that but this image which
lives in our Docs is kind of trying to
explain to you that we have these
checkpoints that happen we check for
sensing we check for motion we check for
pattern we check for huesemann so that
if you're just like walking away to wash
your hands or whatever you're not gonna
come back in your phone's out-of-date
we're stepping into those from an
inactive state so that we can be plinth
like plenty confident that the user is
actually done right now like they're
doing something else okay
so those states are controlled by device
idle controller you can actually look
into the AOSP if you want to know how
this works but all you need to really
believe me is that you've got a good
two hours of inactivity probably before
we get into doze mode so you won't you
won't end up in the state where your app
is just like cut off in the middle of
doing something so active is where the
device is actually being used so that's
pretty obvious right and inactive is
obviously where it's not being used the
screen has been turned off and there's
no motion
we're not navigating we're not playing a
song we don't have a foreground process
running we're just we're just chilling
in in someone's purse right and then
after half an hour device idle
controller kicks back up kicks into idle
pending mode because it's all that we
were interactive
nothing changed no other signals are
processed and now we're just pending so
we've been inactive for a while we may
become idle but we're waiting to be
confident and once we're confident in
half an hour later we're like okay we're
idle this is does everybody this is
happening shut it down and then use all
those maintenance windows that's
measured by idle mean it's about and we
also have like a sensing in a locating
mode and if you want to know more about
those you can actually go look them up
in the documentation they just serve
with getting to these states so if you
go back to look at our picture you'll
see that we've moved it through all of
these states with all of our constant
checks and we have gotten to the point
where okay yeah we were sensing not
sensing locating not locating but we're
still inactive we've gotten to idle and
so idle maintenance these other windows
is actually where we step out of doze
because we understand that you don't
want to be out of date when the user
comes back right and so what we're going
to do is we're going to every so often
in the idle period we'll just you know
if I want to break let them run their
sinks their jobs update any content and
then go straight back into idle mode and
this is clearing because it's our goal
we got to maintenance window now we get
to run everything in a batch everything
that's pending gets a chance to go and
the user still hasn't come back to their
phone so there's really no actual change
to the device but your app gets a chance
to update any potential like conflicts
or content that needs to go so look
we're so close to solving our battery
problem right like we're there we had
her we had our little I can't go
backward
that's unfortunate this is I'm bad at
slides
okay so we had our window we got to hit
our window we got to run all of our
batch jobs and we hit our goal so now
that you understand how these states
work what's the reason I went into this
background is so that you'll understand
what it means when I tell you to test
your app for DOS because we have to do
super great adb commands that will let
you step through all the states so you
can see what your app is doing along the
way and you wouldn't really understand I
meant by step if you didn't understand
what I meant by stages see see how I did
that okay so your focus is on observing
behavior when you're doing this and you
seeing whether your app recovers
gracefully windows exits because
remember we're aiming to not have to do
any work as a result of this mode so
we're looking at this a TV thing you
know dumps this is just a binary that
lets you access other tools by name and
then you've got device idle and this is
a new service that was introduced so
that you could manage the device idle
controller and then obviously step will
let you do those steps and H will show
you all the other options you have and
then the other key to testing is you
need to indicate that the device has to
be unplugged most likely when you're
testing and running a TV can see your
plugged in your phone to the computer
and now you're charging so you have to
like cancel that but when you're
stepping through and you're testing your
device all you're seeing here is like
whether or not you're surprised by
anything whether or not that pause has
actually broken a part of your app
behavior and the idea here when we when
we created this is that it shouldn't
because everything is on hold
everything's been pauses not anywhere
near their phone and yet you're getting
a chance to still update any potential
content so now the question is how do we
get out of doze mode and like what what
does it really mean when we've called it
quits and like we're done so the clear
one here is if the dice is plugged in we
don't care anymore about whether or not
we're preserving battery because we're
charging or if the dice is picked up I'm
so bad at slides then the users clearly
interested in using it again the other
thing though is that if there's an alarm
and not an alarm in a driller but like
an alarm like an alarm clock then we're
going to exit doze mode well before that
so everyone has a chance to sink before
that user wakes up from their nap right
like that's a really key thing here so
we've built this entire system with one
goal of preserving the battery life
and then we built it around making a
great user experience so they never know
that their device was idle all they know
is that they were gone for two days
because they were hanging out their
friends and going camping and they came
back and their tablet still works they
pick it up everything's great and the
tablets still charge like it didn't die
and that's a phenomenal experience and
if we can nail that we're gonna really
really make it so that everything just
is great and it also means that your app
is no longer to blame in the battery
list and they come back and they're
their thing is dead and like why you
know why was the news running if I
wasn't even here to read it like that
doesn't make any sense to me
so hopefully you don't have to do
anything you tested your app once make
sure like it nothing wonky happen and
then you saw okay great
I'm good I'm done but if you actually do
have a use case and you want to adapt
your app for dos here's what you need to
do first up consider the flow of your
app kind of talked about this but will
does affect it if you think about how
your background syncs run and your jobs
run how important are they to the core
function of your app when it's on a time
schedule or if what expectations your
app has for something being done already
likely this shouldn't affect it because
like I said we stepped into this
carefully like we accounted for things
like alarm clocks into user usage but
you know if it does and you'll want to
take a look at that so a common solution
here and this is actually just a general
best practice is to use downstream
messaging if your server is expecting
your device to check in on it and it
misses that connection you might think
that something's wrong but if you've
built your app so that your server sends
interesting information to the device
instead of having to have a call in then
you're going to have just a much better
user experience in general and then if
you're using Google Cloud messaging you
can take us further and have a high
priority tag it's really easy to add you
just add priority high to your data as
you build your object for your message
but a high priority tag is going to be
given exceptions from doze mode it's
going to be given a chance to wake up a
receiver process that message
potentially react to it maybe you need
to generate a notification off of that
and this gives you a temporary reprieve
from doze so most likely you'll go right
back into idle mode but if that
notification draws the users attention
then you're going to be able to like
exit doze went entirely because the
device will have been picked up so you
really get a chance to react to anything
that's critical
like you know real-time messaging and
all kinds of apps like that or maybe a
severe weather I mean it could be any
kind of thing that if I try them but
it's not everything and I want to stress
this because hi
should be treated with care and what
high priority really means it's very
simple to remember this is if I have to
get up walk across the room pick up my
phone when I was doing something more
important like giving a talk and look at
it it better have been worth it and if
it's not worth it because you just
wanted to tell me that I like got a poke
from our friend like that's not the same
thing so not everything's high priority
which is why you add the tag to what
counts and then the rest of the time
everything will be processed normally as
soon as the device is idle again so
we're really trying to build overall
just a great user experience with this
entire program okay the other thing is
some things legitimately are time
critical like you really do need a tutor
at exactly the right moment maybe you
have a reminder app or maybe you have
you know calendar invites going and
these we actually built an alternative
for you we created a new alarm manager
calls so instead of calling set or set
exact you'll add and allow while idle
the methods are actually exactly the
same like they take the same parameters
in the same order they're identical to
their counterparts and all the calling
the only difference is that they're
honored whether or not you're in doze so
it's a really easy swap for any
developer but the one restriction that
we added is that it can only be
triggered once every 15 minutes which is
actually incredibly reasonable if you
think about a device in idle mode if you
didn't get the users attention the first
time they probably don't care two
minutes later right 15 minutes is
actually a very reasonable window and
allows for things like a calendar
reminder without necessarily like you
know triggering a every 60 seconds like
waking up and checking to see if the new
content came in and the final thing
which I already mentioned is you really
need to test your app like make sure
that you don't get surprised or anything
because if you're surprised your users
gonna be surprised and then that's just
going to result in uninstalls or not
using your app or lower engagement
because they don't know how to use it so
classic classic advice here overall
around much as Firdos just test the app
and make sure it works the other thing
is I need to mention that there is a
whitelist for dos it's an exception but
it's only for a few very special use
cases and is subject to the Play Store
developer policy so most of your apps
probably won't need this but if you do
have questions you can feel free to ask
me later or check the documentation on
how that whitelist works okay so that's
doze mode it has a counterpart and
that's called apps
and this is also intrusive marshmallow
also affects all M devices whether or
not you're targeting it but the
difference here is that ab standby was
created for apps while the device is
still running while those such on the
entire device
so while doze might result in maybe
everything being out of sync by about
four hours app standby could mean that
your app hasn't gotten any attention in
a couple of days and that's why you have
to think about this differently but
again we have one goal preserving
battery life and so that's the main
thing to keep in mind as you go through
this so it's the exact same problem
before we need to achieve this as much
as we can and abs that aren't being used
or a drain on the battery when they're
sinking and so we want to batch all of
those and our maintenance windows will
let us do that so kind of like why have
both and here's the main use case so app
standby and O's are different in the
main sense of what they effect an app at
a time or the entire device they both
restrict network access so that you know
nobody can access the radio while
they're in this mode
they both halt all jobs and sinks
because those are the things we want to
batch but alarms and wakelocks are both
going to be honored while we are in app
standby and this is what's going to make
all of the difference because if your
app hasn't been used in a while but it's
put on the standby list and then your
alarm is triggered because you have like
maybe a daily reminder or you have
something that's important and you need
to present that to the user and get
their attention back to your app you're
out of app standby like as soon as you
present a notification like that's like
you're good to go so you're not forced
by the system you're just kind of halted
while the system notices you're not
being used and then as soon as you are
being used you're immediately released
and you have a little bit of control
over how that gets triggered okay so
when your app is actually put on standby
it's because the user isn't using you
they haven't opened your app they
haven't interacted with your app they
haven't like really kind of like touched
it at all in quite a long while and you
don't have a foreground service or
activity or another app using a
foreground service that you wrote you're
not playing any music you're not
streaming and you think you're just kind
of chilling and then finally you don't
have any pending notifications and so
this is my honor and wake locks and
alarms are so important because you do
have a chance to yourself out of standby
but for the most part you are
put on standby because you were actually
like just showing like nobody was using
you so it's not that you're not a
successful app like you're still passing
the toothbrush test it's just the other
23 hours of the day
okay so app standby ends when the user
launches your app obviously or the
device is plugged in when all apps are
released from standby mode because they
don't worry about power anymore or when
any work that you're doing based on your
way clock or your alarm manager is
creating a notification super super easy
but I guess you're kind of wondering
like why really bother with that if it's
so much controlled by the developer the
main thing about app standby is when
you're in app standby mode we offer
those periodic maintenance windows
similar to doze and you have a
guaranteed maintenance window of at
least once every 24 hours
so think about an app that you don't use
often like maybe a movie player right
like you want it to be ready when you're
ready to buy or rent or stream a movie
but you're not going to open it every
day or multiple times a day however all
of that content that it offers to you
that's licensed content and if you don't
update that license regularly you're
legally obligated to delete the content
right because it's an ownership question
and so in order to let the content be
refreshed and change the list of like
movies and in order to make sure they're
all valid from the things you already
paid for as a user you need a periodic
maintenance window but your app doesn't
need to be syncing like all the time or
like three times a day because no one
you might not use it for two months at a
time but it doesn't mean it's not one of
your go-to apps
similar to things like you know buying
movies you like all of these things are
very useful applications they're just
not used all day long and that's why we
created this because we want to empower
those applications but also trying to
like let them know that they're not you
know don't drain the battery like we'll
put you together with a bunch of others
and everyone will have a much better
time but the trick here is you probably
still don't have to do anything if
you're reacting to a broadcast or a
message the way you normally would then
you're going to produce a notification
and getting yourself out of standby and
if you're you know building an app that
like runs sync every so often it'll
still run everyday like still hitting my
goal from the beginning we're not
changing anything but when you do need
to adapt perhaps standby it's exactly
the same as before a GCM high-priority
message will break through and give you
a network access that you can run a sync
in response to some sort of message
and so really all you have to do is a
couple of tweaks here and then you're
you're really good to go
like if anything like I said maybe it
doesn't affect your app but that CPU
time that Network access you can get it
when it responds to something important
but you know keep in mind what counts as
high priority if you don't want to get
up from writing some code and go and
check your phone probably don't mean
your user to have to like interrupt
their date when they're not actually on
the device okay so this results in a
final list of like why why did you you
know tell me all this like why do I
actually have to do do I have to like
test my app or not and I mean you do
that's true both app standby and doze
they're going to be affecting your app
like no matter what you do you're kind
of stuck with it it's part of
marshmallow devices it's coming so you
should be considering this already but
you know we need to keep radio and CPU
off as long as possible so device can
stay on and you have to have all apps
participating in this to achieve this
goal
just a few inactive are just a few
active ones that are exceptions that can
actually undermine the entire purpose of
an idle mode right so the key here is to
understand what has changed you can't
depend solely on wake locks and alarms
because their behavior isn't exactly
right and if you have something that is
critical or sensitive you're kind of you
know you're catching yourself here
however you can count on the fact that
all of these things are going to trigger
they just might be deferred so really
nothing changes in the overall picture
it just like I said you may be in a
situation where dosas put your device a
couple hours out of date and you won't
notice that until the user picks it up
and then it runs the sync so maybe
there's a long loading window and if
that's bad for your application you need
to be considering that when you're
scheduling your jobs and your sinks
which leads to my to-do list SuperDuper
hard like I said considering the flow of
your app you need to make sure that
everything behaves the way that it
should behave for the best user
experience with the potential of being a
couple hours late you need to update any
time critical alarms to include and
allow while idle and you need to
consider any urgent or critical
downstream messages as high-priority
with GCM and finally you really have to
actually test your app you need to see
how it reacts to a sink or a job when
it's delayed because of doze and if
you're not happy you have to return to
step one and do the whole thing again
but if you actually are
then you're done like that's all the
integration that's required for dough's
which leads me up here to stand up here
and stress again this sounds like a
really frustrating thing because
developers don't have any power here but
we actually designed it so thoughtfully
that you shouldn't have to do hardly
anything at all there are a few special
cases that we really to think about like
you really do need to know what's going
on here what's going on there and then
maybe you're frustrated cuz the
15-minute window doesn't work for you
but you're also considering the fact if
if you can't get the users attention
with a alarm every 15 minutes they might
really be doing something important
which goes back to my toothbrush test
like users do have lives and it's hard
to remember that because you get into
this point where you've spent your whole
life kind of like every day building
this thing that matters so much to you
but if you think about it from a user
perspective how how do you use it and
how how will you use or use it and what
does it do to the battery we're all
trying to make a better system here make
a better ecosystem and that's why we
have done so test it test it thoroughly
test it using ADB it's pretty great and
we have a special one also for app
standby with inactive and you can set
inactive or not to see you put yourself
on the standby list and see how your app
interacts there all of this is
documented thoroughly online we have a
couple of videos to help you out and of
course you can always message me with
specific questions or any feedback or
anything you want to know if you want to
learn more about how actually a
background tasks work in general I'm
gonna go over that at four o'clock how
to use job service how to build an
intent service or use a broadcast
receiver how to actually make a
background test because that's a
completely different problem but as for
saving your tests from doze mode you
really hopefully shouldn't have to worry
it shouldn't be any work for you and I
hope that that's what you discover with
your app okay cool you're all done
really early so if you want to ask me
questions I'll just be like right here
you've got 15 minutes every day back to
go get lunch